aquí tenemos una variable aleatoria
geométrica clásica la definimos como el
número de ejecuciones independientes
para tener éxito donde la probabilidad
de éxito para cada ejecución es p
minúscula ya hemos visto esto antes
cuando comenzamos a ver las variables
geométricas el propósito de este vídeo
es deducir cuál es el valor esperado de
una variable aleatoria geométrica como
ésta les voy a dar la respuesta ahora y
en los próximos vídeos
vamos a aplicar esta fórmula en este
vídeo veremos la demostración matemática
el valor esperado de una variable
aleatoria geométrica es el inverso de la
probabilidad de una ejecución exitosa
ahora vamos a demostrarlo el valor
esperado de cualquier variable aleatoria
es la suma de los resultados que podemos
tener ponderados por su probabilidad es
decir la probabilidad de que nuestra
variable aleatoria sea igual a 1 por 1
más la probabilidad de que la variable
aleatoria sea igual a 2 multiplicado por
dos y así sucesivamente una variable
aleatoria geométrica sólo puede tener
valores enteros pero
pueden valer cero porque no podemos
tener un éxito si no tenemos al menos
una ejecución a que se hará igual esto
cuál es la probabilidad de tener éxito
en la primera ejecución va a ser igual a
p y esto aquí será igual cuál es la
probabilidad de que no tengamos un éxito
en la primera ejecución y que tengamos
éxito en la segunda ejecución esto es
igual a 1 - p por la probabilidad de
éxito en la segunda ejecución permítanme
escribir un término más aquí más la
probabilidad de que x sea igual a 3 x 3
y esto que es igual la probabilidad de
que x sea igual a 3 es igual a la
probabilidad de fallar en las dos
primeras ejecuciones
1 - p al cuadrado y después
multiplicarlo por una ejecución exitosa
con esto ya tenemos una idea de lo que
sucede vamos a reescribir lo para
simplificar lo el valor esperado de x es
igual a 1 p más 2 p por 1 p más 3 p por
uno menos p al cuadrado y así
sucesivamente como podemos calcular la
suma ahora vamos a aplicar
trucos matemáticos parecidos a los que
usamos para la demostración de una serie
geométrica infinita
ahora vamos a preguntarnos a qué es
igual esto 1 - p por este valor esperado
voy a multiplicar todos estos términos
por 1 - p 1 p por 1 - p va a ser igual a
1 p por 1 - p2p por 1 - p por 1 - p será
2 p por 1 - p x lo mismo que es 1 - p al
cuadrado pueden ver cómo continúa esto
ahora vamos a hacer algo bastante
interesante y divertido desde el punto
de vista matemático como en ambas
ecuaciones el lado derecho es igual al
lado izquierdo prestemos la ecuación de
abajo de la ecuación de arriba nos queda
el valor esperado de x que es este menos
uno
- p por el valor esperado de x estamos
restando esto de este lado y ahora
hagamos lo mismo del lado derecho
nos queda 1 p y luego restó 1 p por 1 -
p2p por 1 - p y nos queda 1 p
por 1p si le restó esto a esto nos queda
uno por uno
al cuadrado y así continuamos
sucesivamente vamos a simplificar esto
distribuimos el signo negativo y nos
queda más p menos uno y si distribuimos
el valor esperado de x del lado
izquierdo nos queda
permítanme mover un poco la pantalla
para tener más espacio nos queda el
valor esperado de x más p por el valor
esperado de x menos el valor esperado de
x estas se cancelan y nos queda que es
igual a peu más p por 1p más pp por 1 -
p al cuadrado y así sucesivamente del
lado izquierdo me queda p por el valor
esperado de x y para despejar el valor
esperado de x vivido a ambos lados entre
p y como resultado de estos trucos
matemáticos tenemos que del lado
izquierdo nos queda el valor esperado de
x mientras que del lado derecho tenemos
uno más uno menos p más uno menos p al
cuadrado y así sucesivamente
esto que nos queda es una serie
geométrica clásica con una
en común de 1 p esta es una de las
razones por las que a este tipo de
variables aleatorias se les llama
variables aleatorias geométricas y si
esto es algo que no les es familiar los
invito a que vean los vídeos que tenemos
sobre series geométricas en otros vídeos
hemos demostrado usando técnicas
similares a las que utilizamos aquí que
esta suma es igual a 1 entre 1 menos
nuestra razón común que en este caso es
1 - p al final de cuentas esto a que va
a ser igual ya estamos en la recta final
esto es igual a 1 entre uno menos uno
más
esto se cancela y nos queda uno entre p
con esto hemos demostrado usando trucos
matemáticos geniales que el valor
esperado de una variable aleatoria
geométrica es igual a uno entre p y con
esto terminamos